temperature I got hooked into space as a
child of the Apollo era when I was 10
years old my dad brought home eight
millimeter footage from NASA and he
would project it on the wall of my
bedroom and it was the view of this
strange triangular window of the lunar
module and this moon scape was a rising
up and there were no trees there's no
vegetation there's no rubble or walls
and it's an obviously an alien world and
I imagine myself in that lunar module
descending down to an alien moon and
that man my name is Cameron Smith I'm
building a DIY spaceship so I'm excited
by being a very tiny part of the
evolutionary future of our species which
is space settlement this is one little
piece of the puzzle that I can
contribute the Apollo moon program
that's 400,000 engineers across the
United States know one of them could
have built the whole moon program every
single one though contributed a tiny
piece so what part can i play in space
settlement a little bit of advance maybe
in in space suits I'm very lucky to have
volunteers who've taking their own time
from their lives they build pieces of
equipment they help out in the tests
communications gear and thermal probe in
bag Tom's and the thermal probe are
through the bag my dream when I was 10
of course was to go into NASA comm check
one two
comm check one two at that time the path
to NASA was through military aviation so
I thought alright I'll fly for the Navy
and I started looking into it and I
discovered that you had to have perfect
vision to fly in the front seat to be
the pilot and my vision wasn't exactly
perfect so I had to pick a different
path but I was able to learn about
evolution and now apply evolutionary
principles to adaptation to space once I
decided that I would try to contribute
to human space settlement by building
cheaper and lighter spacesuits I thought
I would look at the
three of space suits so I looked into
the 1930s when they were building
pressure suits for very high altitude
balloon flight and I saw that these were
made from very crude materials canvas
painted with rubber to make it gas tight
pigskin gloves basically a bucket in a
glass faceplate for a helmet some of
them got to fifty sixty thousand feet in
balloons none of them were killed
immediately by this and I thought if
they could do this in the 1930s with the
materials available in the 1930s surely
70 you know almost a hundred years later
I could do it today there are four main
layers to pretty much any spacesuit the
first one is a thermal garment and this
either cools or warms you depending on
the conditions the second layer is a gas
tight pressure barrier this holds the
bubble of pressure around the body and
prevents decompression sickness third
layer is a coverall it gives you pockets
to carry things in it allows you to
attach hardware it's also protection
against abrasion and punctures of the
pressure bladder the fourth layer is
really a set of components that are
attached the gloves the helmet there are
boots and then there are a whole set of
fittings ports where gas fluids and
electrical power go in and out of the
suit giving us communications control of
the carbon dioxide level inside so my
paradigm for the spacesuit is to get
away from the holy relic to get away
from the idea that it's this super
special thing that only a few people can
touch and you need a very experienced
technician to fix it my paradigm is the
Ford pickup truck
I want the Ford pickup truck of
spacesuits cheap durable highly reliable
and I can fix it myself
I wonder how this will
idiotic seeming the more common
materials that I use are hose clamps we
use those you use them in your car to
clamp hoses onto pipes we use them for
pressure closures the wiring inside the
spacesuit is not much more complicated
than in an old pickup truck we do a few
things we insulate everything so you
can't get a spark because we breathe
100% oxygen so you'd blow up but really
we're using twelve or twenty gauge wire
just like you buy at the hardware store
we started to make it more comfortable
and more reasonable to actually be in
these we used to have a really sort of
atomic wedgie effect though the whole
suit would pull up into your crotch it
was really bad okay we cut the suits
little bit now that's gone away ready
one two three
[Applause]
once the suit is assembled one of the
first tests is simply does it maintain
this essential pressure so we put a
person into it we run the coolant we run
the communication system we just check
it all out
used to be a really special thing
getting in you know once a month you get
into this suit and it's really special
now it's almost routine once you're
inside though it's still in an adventure
every time all five of your senses are
engaged what you're breathing the taste
and the odor is different because it's
coming from a canister of oxygen the
sounds are strange you hear pumps you
hear hissing you hear people talking on
the radio not just the normal voice
we like to take the suits outside and
put them into the real world
gritty conditions so we'll go down to
the river and we'll get in the water and
we'll see you know is it leaking is it
able to sustain you know again if we
crash land on earth in water and we need
to climb into our survival raft
we've also tested in altitude chambers
and they pumped the pressure down and
used to simulate high altitudes and the
spacesuit must work at that time and it
has but even that's a sterile controlled
environment and so now we're going to
start flying in the spacesuit to high
altitudes in my balloon and we'll slowly
go to higher and higher altitudes and
the natural world will be our pressure
chamber I've been working on this since
2008 my first drawing of a concept of
flying in a balloon in a suit that I'm
wearing myself but I built myself the
date on that is 2008 and then I spent a
year doing research and then I started
building things
so roughly 10 years I don't know how
much I've spent I've spent everything
that is available to me probably less
than $30,000 by this point and that's
you know that's why I work is to have
money for adventures and and projects
like this my plan is to make it all
open-source so I'll take all of our
plans everything that we've done and
that goes online and people can go there
and download it and I hope the people
will then make improvements on it the
more people you have making iterations
on it the more likely one person is
going to have a great design and that
will be maybe you know the next
fundamental design for space suits I
hope a lot of space suit designs are
iterated and then a few will result from
this and they make space suit design
better
you
[Music]